on peut le faire vous aussi allez vous
regarder on applaudit schumi a augmenté
ses prix significativement j'en ai déjà
parlé dans la dernière vidéo où je vous
écrivais ce grand message innovation for
everyone le papier recyclé ya encore des
notes dessus
et pour cause puisqu'ils sont montés en
gamme avec un me disent pro elles me
disent pro il est là je m'amuse avec et
je peux vous assurer qu'il est vachement
bien et c'est ça que j'aime dans cette
période de l'année vous savez où tout le
monde lance son smartphone tout le monde
arrive avec des grosses pec des fiches
techniques hyper boost est pour vous
proposer ce qui se fait de mieux pour
vos usagers pour vos besoins et quand on
voit une réussite parce que franchement
chez tommy a très bien bossé je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi
et bien c'est passionnant surtout pour
des gens comme moi qui semble un peu au
milieu qui comptent les points
aujourd'hui à l'instant t
schumi a le meilleur score sur en tout
ou au niveau des benchmarks vous
expliquer ça je vous détailler sa avant
toute chose avant de vous parler
justement de ce midi ce professionnel je
vais faire comme je le fais dans mes
vidéos pendant le confinement vous
m'envoyer vos vidéos l'e-mail qui
s'affiche juste en dessous amour @
monsieur gros point fr nous envoyer de
l'amour et aujourd'hui on va se partager
une vidéo qui nous envoient également
toujours de l'amour et d'ailleurs vous
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer votre vidéo à
abu @ monsieur gros point fr salue
monsieur drevet toute la communauté
alors moi je m'appelle bâtisse yogini
âge 18 ans j'habite au nord de toulouse
donc la semaine dernière on a eu un peu
de soleil c'est cool on a pu faire un
deux barbecues donc je vis dans une
maison et j'en ai la chance d'ailleurs
en tant qu'étudiant parce que je sais
qu'il y en a plein qui sont un
appartement donc d'ailleurs gros big up
à vous parce que je sais que c'est pas
forcément facile donc moi je suis en
première année de médecine
ce qui fait qu'on a pas mal de pain sur
la planche le taf
ça ne colle pas donc du coup
en plus de ça notre concours a été
décalé donc comme beaucoup de passes est
ce que je soutiens beaucoup et
d'ailleurs toutes les personnes soient
en médecine actuellement que ce soit des
étudiants ou des médecins je sais que
c'est difficile je vous encourage tous
c'est pour vous dire en conclusion
générale au confinement
occupez vous comme vous pouvez on a
internet avant les années passent à fort
profité à plus merci merci merci merci
merci infiniment
je regarde toutes vos vidéos j'en ai
plusieurs qui sont deux côtés elles
arriveront au fur et à mesure et quelles
que soient vos vidéos merci à vous tous
de participer de les envoyer
et croyez moi quand je les regarde et
que j'ai téléchargé et que je mets
lecture c'est toujours un vrai plaisir
pour découvrir votre univers ce que vous
partagez sur ce on va donc parler de ce
smartphone le milices pro le milices pro
c'est d'abord aux smartphones qu'à une
prise en main qui est quand même plutôt
pas mal
un peu grande par rapport à d'autres
smartphones on peut retrouver début 2020
il est notamment plus grand que le p 40
pro 2 voies ouvertes jarry venu afin de
tourner au niveau du pk rangs pros que
je le fais avec les milices pro bon par
contre c'est beaucoup plus dur avec
iphone os promax moi aussi j'ai une
couleur mate c'est le bleu alpin qui ne
prend absolument pas les traces de
doigts il fait 2 108 grammes c'est pas
le plus léger mais c'est pas très
dérangeant le capteur d'empreintes
digitales situe ici et déverrouille
extrêmement rapidement on a bien
évidemment la petite caméra qui est
planqué là le menton n'est pas
particulièrement proéminents et d'un
point de vue général j'aime beaucoup le
travail qu'a fait shiomi là dessus avec
son écran incurvé qui est vraiment bien
ça c'est pour la partie extérieure mais
dans un smartphone le plus beau se
trouve à l'intérieur
et justement à l'intérieur on a des
choses qui sont vraiment bien mais vif
technique pour fiche technique je dirais
qu'on s'en fiche ce qui est le plus
important sont les usages est-ce que ça
va venir vous apporter le premier gros
usages c'est multimédia on veut pouvoir
venir regarder des séries des films
youtube on veut pouvoir avoir une bonne
expérience de gaming on vous pouvoir
avoir une bonne expérience en naviguant
sur les réseaux sociaux et pour tout ça
il vous faut un bon écran avec de bons
parleurs il vous faut smartphone nokia
n8 qui n'est pas de latence et qui a une
bonne autonomie pour vous puissiez le
faire quand vous voulez sans vous poser
de questions votre écran globalement est
plutôt bien calibré ce que je vous
conseille quand même c'est de venir ici
dans les schémas de couleur et vous
venez active et chaud ça vient
légèrement jauni à l'écran vous restez
bien en couleurs automatique par contre
ça vient réchauffer l'écran et c'est
quand même beaucoup plus agréable pour
vos yeux je vous conseille également de
venir cocher la case anti scintillement
vous en rendez pas compte ça venait
éviter la fatigue oculaire et le 2
une gros usages c'est la partie photo
vous voulez un smartphone pour faire de
très bonnes photos pour pouvoir les
partager
pour pouvoir les imprimés et pour
pouvoir aussi les archives et on vous
donc que la fiche technique répondent à
nos besoins
et c'est justement ça que se met 10 pro
est vachement bien parce que la qualité
d'affichage il avec son écran amoled de
6,7 pouces de diagonale l'expérience est
vraiment bien on a ici un écran 90 hier
ce qui est vachement bien pour venir
scrollé naviguer ça c'est vraiment cool
alors ici pas d'écran 120 hertz mais ce
n'est que 90e sa porte quand même
vachement de fluidité et pour la
fluidité lorsque j'ai bien joué à des
jeunes époque j à tout ce que vous
voulez eh ben c'est vachement bien
on est une machine qui est très très
puissante c'est extrêmement fluide et ça
c'est vraiment bluffante en plus haut
que la colorimétrie vraiment bien
maîtrisée ici qui dit écran amoled
d'idées noires parfait des couleurs qui
sont extrêmement maîtrisé on s'en rend
pas compte
au travers de la caméra comme ça puisque
vous assurer qu'en le regardant en
naviguant on profite du vrai bol
d'expérience d'affichage donc la partie
d'affichage très précisément est
vraiment bien réussi mais pour moi il ya
un point qui est aussi vraiment top et
qui est souvent un petit peu négligé ou
qui n'est pas parfait c'est la partie
audio élèves xiaoming la sortie un truc
qui est absolument incroyable
je vous le montre là dessus le premier
parleurs qui est la 2e haut-parleurs et
là vous avez vraiment la même
spatialisation vous avez beaucoup de son
le son de qualité et quand vous jouez à
des jeux que vous regardez les films on
sent que le ce on arrive d'un côté glock
s'est complètement uniforme et ça c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment incroyable
parce que si on n'a pas des petits haut
parleurs qui font coin coin on n'a pas
les petits haut parleurs avec un son
extrêmement un médium on a des haut
parleurs qui vous délivre inspectent qui
est quand même assez lâche parce que
vous jouez à des jeux vous vous repérez
vraiment dans l'espace lorsque vous
regardez un film vous écouter la musique
vous avez vraiment un son stéréo qui
sort de bonne qualité pas de
déséquilibre et ça c'est extrêmement
appréciable donc pour les usages
multimédias et bien cocher une case de
plus l'écran est bon l'audio est bon ça
c'est vraiment bien maintenant ce qu'on
veut c'est de la performance qu'on veut
pas se poser la question est ce que mon
smartphone risque de lag et un moment
est-ce qu'il va couper ce qu'il va ramer
est ce qu'il va être moins performant on
veut pas ça on veut pas se poser ces
questions ce qu'on veut c'est au
smartphone fonctionne bien tout le temps
et qu'on ne s'en rendent pas compte
on veut juste qu'ils marchent un point
c'est tout c'est justement là dessus
j'ai omis a aussi sorti le grand jeu
puisque la technologie de rome c'est de
la lpddr2 5
ça c'est ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui que vous avez 8
dia de ram et la techno de stockage
c'est de lui fs 3.0 autant diax avec
plus rapide en lecture en écriture que
le ffs deux points qui si vous n'avez
pas et sur le modèle pro vous avez
obligatoirement 256 gigaoctets de
stockage
mais ce n'est pas tout puisqu'il dispose
actuellement du processeur de smartphone
le plus puissant sur le marché c'est le
stade ragots 865 de qualcomm donc vous
prenez tout ça vous ne rassemblez vous
l'optimiser d'un point de vue logiciel
et vous sortez un smartphone qui arrive
numéro 1 sur un tout où il est le score
de 594 mhz 1242 et ça vient classé
numéro 1 oui ici numéro un au dessus du
galaxy s va ultra 5 g avec le sale gosse
865 au dessus du galaxy s 20 plus à des
classes à dragon 165 au dessus du galaxy
s valtra 5 g les deux mêmes avec les
processeur exynos est au dessus du rock
fun ii d'asus
alors tout ça se joue dans un mouchoir
de poche mais c'est vachement
intéressant parce que comme je vous le
dis c'est une photo prise à un instant
terres qui sont des smartphones sortie
on en reparlera dans quelques temps et
c'est vraiment là où on pourra avoir une
vision un peu plus globale c'est très
serré entre 5 194 milles et 162 milles
l'écart est pas énorme mais ce qui est
très drôle c'est que lui le numéro un
est la 8 giga draps et vous prenez le
samsung galaxy s veille 3 5g avec le
sunrise 865 vous avez douzy jadran donc
le test tel qu'il est réalisé par nous
tous vous le classe numéro un ce qui
veut donc dire que ce smartphone coche
une case de plus quand on fait qu'il ne
rame pas et qui sera toujours là pour
répondre à vos besoins quels que soient
vos usages alors après il ya peu que moi
je fais un peu moins fans que je trouve
un peu moins bon c'est à dire que
lorsque vous allez dans vos paramètres
vous allez ensuite dans affichage
jusque là vous nous suivez ya un bien
difficile vous allez dans taux
d'actualisation salle et vous allez
choisir le taux de rafraîchissement de
vos smartphones si vous voulez un taux
de rafraîchissement en 90 hertz ou en 60
hertz ça veut dire quoi hertz pas si
vous êtes coutumier totalement
c'est le nombre d'image que vous allez
avoir par seconde c'est à dire que sur
60 hertz vous allez avoir 60 images par
seconde et si vous montez en 90 heures
vous allez voir 92 images par secondes
ça veut dire plus d'image en une seconde
ça veut dire un résultat qui sera plus
fluide
c'est quelque chose qui sera beaucoup
plus agréable à vos yeux donc ça c'est
vachement bien maintenant il ya un truc
qui pourrait être amélioré par shiomi
c'est que vous avez choix entre soit 90
et 60 hertz
vous n'avez pas comme d'autres le font
une sélection automatique qui
permettrait aux smartphones de basculer
entre
ou l'autre mode en fonction des réels
besoins de l'application vous êtes en
train d'utiliser ce qui vous permettrait
notamment de venir économiser de la
batterie en switch entendu 60 hertz
lorsque vous n'avez pas besoin d'1 90 m
et ça c'est un peu dommage ça vient un
peu dégradé la question de l'autonomie
et je pense que ça sera un point à
améliorer au niveau de me wade après et
soyez rassurez vous êtes quand même une
grosse batterie de 4500 millions terreur
vous permettra de tenir un jour et demi
voire un peu plus si affinités c'est
toutefois vous avez un problème vous
avez de la recharge extrêmement rapide
donc vous aurez call branchez une
demi-heure pour repartir sans aucun
problème donc mis à part ce petit bémol
ils cochent toutes les cases c'est dur à
dire ils cochent toutes les cases donc
pour votre usage multimédia là dessus
vous êtes vraiment tranquille et
maintenant qu'en est-il de l'usaj photo
et là ça devient vachement intéressante
le tout premier de ces zooms x 5 en
dessous c'est un zoom x de l'art ici
c'est la caméra tough qui vous servira
pour la profondeur qui situés juste là
en dessous vous avez votre capteur de
100 8 mégapixels est en dessous vous
avez votre ultra grand angle qui servira
également pour la macro c'est pas pour
faire la fiche technique parce que je
voulais déjà montré dans la vidéo de
présentation
mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que pour le capteur principal ici c'est
le sens 8 mégapixels qui sortira des
photos en 27 mégapixels et ensuite vous
allez pouvoir venir zoom est très
facilement et façon complètement
intelligente entre fois deux optiques
qui va venir le monter sur un fois cette
optique nous avons trois buts sur
infodis hybride jusqu'à 1 x 50 numérique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout ça ça
veut dire que je suis au mit a voulu
faire une vraie montée en gamme a
vraiment voulu aller plus loin en termes
de photos on l'a déjà vu et dernière sur
le min 10 avec la première caméra ce
sont 8 mégapixels ça c'était déjà plutôt
pas mal et là je trouve qu'avec ce combo
gagnant de cinq caméras
eh bien on a tous qui est plutôt
intéressant on a même des
fonctionnalités qui certes un peu à rien
comme l'a84 vidéo bon choix et la
qualité des images est là c'est pas mal
les couleurs sont jolies mais
aujourd'hui travailler de l'a8 en vidéo
ça vous servir à rien mieux vaut filmé
en 4k donc plus que là dessus si vous
voulez avoir de l'hyper stabilisation
une vraie bonne stabilisation vous aller
filmer en full hd en 1080p à 30 images
par seconde donc c'est pas la peine de
s'exciter sur la burqa en main vous
posiez sur un trépied que vous ayez des
conditions complètement optimale et une
machine arrière suffisamment puissante
pour venir travailler tout ça et puis
des écrans après pour me rafraîchir les
huit cas si nombre global montre ça
servira pas à grand chose
ça c'est un peu pour balancer de l'aspec
pour valence et de la stricte dit ronald
à huit cas on le fait aussi attention
prenez au sérieux parce que oui
effectivement le problème là-dessus
qu'aujourd'hui à schumi c'est à dire
prenez nous au sérieux sur un smartphone
à 1000 euros parce que dans l'esprit de
tout le monde
les smartphones ici on mise sur les
smartphones pas cher avec des bosses
spec des smartphones qui marche combien
mais d'un point de vue pécuniaire c'est
pas extrêmement cher même si vous
arriviez à 500 600 euros on n'était pas
sur un smartphone à 1000 euros là ils
viennent se positionner là dessus
ils sont donc obligés de montrer les
muscles et dire ok regarder on fait nous
aussi de la vidéo en 8k
on est donc hyper malaise pourrait donc
compter sur nous pour l'achat d'un
smartphone très haut de gamme
on va se regarder la partie photo du
midi ici on est sur l'ultra grand angle
caméra principale x 2 x 5 et on se
rapproche on se rapproche on se
rapproche vous en douterez plus on va se
rapprocher et plus on va avoir du bruit
ça ça me paraît quand même normal caméra
principale ultra grand angle différent
de colorimétrie entre la caméra
principale est ultra grand-angle luttera
grand temps l'écart même plus saturé on
vient aussi passés sur le x 2 le
résultat est vraiment bien
x 5 c'est aussi pas mal caméra
principale ultra grand angle
c'est beaucoup plus vert x 2 x 5 x 10 et
voyait plus on se rapproche et plus on
récupère du bruit et au bout d'un moment
on fois c'est pas terrible luttera
grand-angle à contre-jour caméra
principale fois de regarder la le détail
que vous avez la petite branche là on la
voit bien on la devine bien on voit bien
pour autant le ciel on voit bien les
détails de la bri si on voit bien le mur
rien des cram et il ya vraiment très
beau travail qui fait ici
vous le voyez même ici les au niveau des
détails des plantes vous voyez bien des
petites fleurs derrière vous voyez bien
les petites branches qui montrent selon
la brr le rendu est vraiment extrêmement
bien maîtriser là dessus les mais
maintenant vous rapprochez on regarde
bien les petites branches ici on voit
bien ce qu'on a devant da bien ici il ya
vraiment un super beau travail logiciels
un dessin de la macro alors moi je suis
surpris parce que vous savez la macro
règle générale j'aime pas trop peu comme
si la caméra ultra grand-angle de 20
mégapixels qui fait de la macro et bien
le résultat bien meilleur pour une fois
mais la macro qui est quand même pas mal
alors macro macro séparément la complète
macro il y en ayant des résultats qui
sont vraiment qualitatif regarder ça de
détails sur les branches
ça c'est vachement bien pour la fleur et
si j'ai pas que ça à faire le point
c'est flou ça c'est quand même un peu
dommage me suis mis trop près mais là la
rose regarder le résultat est vraiment
bien même en revenant se rapprocher pour
une formule ford la macro qui sert à
quelque chose et on peut venir se
rapprocher zoomer regarder on a vraiment
tous les petits détails
ça c'est vachement bien et surtout il ya
une très très très bonne gestion de la
plage dynamique vous l'apprendre dans
tous les sens ça marche
vachement bien mais maintenant vous
rapprochez on nous met alors en bout
d'un moment ça finit par lycée mais je
dirais que sur la photo un petit peu
standard si vous cherchez pas trop
pousser bouvier sur des choses comme ça
vous pouvez vraiment faire les choses
super est vraiment vous amuse avec la
photo on va vraiment bien chercheurs
vont se rapprocher ultra-grand-angle
caméra principale x 2 x 5 x 10 ça
commence à lisser et on se rapproche on
se rapproche jusqu à l os x 50 et vous
en douterez soit 50 c'est franchement
pas terrible
ultra grand-angle caméra principale x 2
x 5 x 10 et on se rapproche parfois
cinquante et une fois de plus c'est pas
génial
le rendu au niveau de la caméra telle
fille aussi plutôt bon le mode portrait
fonctionne bien pour le détourage par
contre il a un problème sur la gestion
de la lumière et vous le voyez ici sur
la main et bien c'est tout simplement
cramé dans toutes ces parties là alors
ça j'avais déjà vu notamment sur le
samsung galaxy ace va ultra maintenant
se poser la question de la photo de lui
et la photo nuit je suis assez bluffé on
dirait qu'ici c'est pas la nuit et
pourtant je puis vous assurer qu'ils
aient pas jour qui vous assurer qu'on
n'avait pas un ciel bleu avec beaucoup
de lumière vous avez un truc qui est
vraiment bien et on se croirait presque
en plein jour à votre avis quelle heure
et il alla il doit quelque chose comme à
l'escale et 21h30 et à 21h30
aujourd'hui croyez-moi il c'est nul
comme on a ici un smartphone avec de
l'a50 nos amis en franchissement avec du
graphène je vais tomber de ce tabouret
nom de zeus qui permet effectivement de
mieux dissiper la chaleur presque oui la
5g va faire votre smartphone va chauffer
davantage alors c'est pas le fait de la
5g c'est le fait du matériel que vous
avez à l'intérieur qui fait que ça va
chauffer davantage
donc on a mis système de refroidissement
à base de graphène et qui fonctionne
bien alors moi ici je n'ai pas de 5 g je
n'ai pas d'abonnement 5g la 5g n'est pas
encore déployé mais ça ne saurait tarder
par contre et c'est là où c'est
intéressant c'est que lorsque vous allez
jouer à des jeux pendant des séances de
jeu un peu longue à aucun moment vous
allez sentir de choc de zones chaudes
aux deux nouveaux smartphones donc ça
c'est bien social smartphone cas du wifi
sans fin qui à ce qui se fait de mieux
et c'est vraiment ça qui est intéressant
non pas d'avoir de la débauche
technologique pour eux de la débauche
technologique mais tout simplement pour
dire ok ce smartphone la meute rom et
des usages et au final il tient sa
promesse et c'est ça qui est intéressant
donc si vous voulez acheter un milices
pro c'est avant tout pour la photo par
rapport aux me dise si vous voulez un
excellent smartphone et que la partie
photo eh bien c'est bien mais un petit
peu moins important le lui dise ça très
bien
et un peu moins cher mais le milices pro
pourra voir ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui chez xiaomi et bien c'est
vachement bien et une fois de plus pour
la montée en gamme de survie pour la
réussite de la montée en gamme de survie
bravo schumi a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez commande où trouver ces
milices pro est ce que vous avez déjà eu
un smartphone de chez lui et est ce que
vous pourriez être tenté par ce
smartphone à 1000 euros de chimie qui
eût cru un jour chômé
une amie dont il faut savoir que pendant
toute la période du confinement en
france schumi va faire du porte à porte
pour le sav de vos smartphones
autre point vous avez un remplacement de
l'écran qui est gratuit pendant deux ans
pour les smartphones à compter de la
date d'achat
ça c'est bien également et troisième
point est important chehoumi reverse 50
euros à la fondation ap hp pour l'achat
d'un milices pro et d'un midi du 7 avril
au 7 mai ce smartphone l'aï dit
cependant une seule confie 8 plus de 156
giga à 999 20090 c'est à dire qu'à 10
centime près vous le payez 1000 euros
mais avec si vous le commandez vous avez
les mitrons wireless deux offerts qui
coûte 99 euros 90 en attendant le
produit est là il est bien réussi il
tient ses promesses et ce qui est sûr ce
qu'il va falloir compter cherchiez
hormis toujours plus et même sur les
produits très haut de gamme
sur ce je vous invite à venir tout ce
que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaires et vous fait des gros
bisous ou d'envoi l'amour et à demain
ciao
[Musique]